[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parmi les informations les plus folles
que j'ai lu ces derniers jours celles du
yacht de jeff bezos ce fait ma joie je
l'avais gel des hausses pdg d'amazon
l'homme le plus riche du monde a fait
construire un bateau de 430 millions
d'euros pour ses croisières personnel
430 millions d'euros je n'arrive même
pas à imaginer une telle somme pour un
bateau avis aux amateurs de bonnes
affaires patrick en fait partie les
soldes d'hiver se termine demain ça
passe vite mais il est encore temps d'en
profiter il y en a un qui ne s'est pas
privé c'est la dîmière poutine la
semaine dernière il recevait le
président argentin autour de cette table
de dînette
mais entre temps il a fait les soldes
sur maison du monde
[Rires]
cette embarcation longue 227 mètres avec
trois mâts ne peut pas quitter le
chantier rejoindre la mer puisque le
bateau ne passe pas sous un pont
historique de rotterdam construit en
1878 qu'à cela ne tienne jeff bezos ce a
proposé le démontage et le remontage
dudit pont qu'il prendrait évidemment
assez frais pour que son vaisseau des
mers et des océans prennent le large
encore plus
elle est tellement belle maintenant je
n'ai vu que mes yeux on prend un peu de
recul pour la faire durer le plus
longtemps possible il faut la protéger
quelque chose dont j'étais conscient
avant la mission
si nous ne nous soucions pas de l'autre
de tous les autres colocataires de cette
planète alors ils vont disparaître
et c'est pourquoi il est important de
regarder le tilleul le platane la
mésange la grenouille le triton les vers
de terre
c'est très simple
vous prêtez attention bonjour prêter
attention à sauver le monde à tous et à
toutes bourgeois
c'est la fête
dans l'uriné ya de l'azoté la zone quand
ça se décompose ça fait des nitrates ce
qui est pas du tout bon pour les cours
d'eau et pour les ter il ya aussi le
fait que quand lui rinne se mélange à la
bouse de vache c'est pas très gai le
matin mais quand ça se mélange sacré de
l'ammoniac l'ammoniaque qui est un
poison et qui envoie un gaz toxique et
donc on a inventé mais des pissotières
pour vaches pour justement éviter que ça
turine se mélangent avec la bouse de
vache beaucoup pensent que les
publicités que vous voyez vous vous
entendez à la radio sont là pour les
auditeurs pas du tout les spots
publicitaires sont là pour les membres
de l'équipe c'est pour nous un site et
nous mêmes à acheter et il y en a eu il
ya quelques instants pour vous charlotte
lorsque vous souffrez de dire et c'est
probablement le signal
est donc ça commence a ponctué sa chatte
tous au dessus des pizzas fils à lui
château château est ouvert à tous
suffisamment alors là c'est une petit
déjeuner s'est entraîné ça nous donne
envie de faire pipi et on récupère mieux
ring de la vache non mais c'est très
important parce que comme si on récupère
lloris et une [__] de la main ça se
mélange pas cela se mélange pas la bouse
ça ne pollue pas est un mégot de moins
dans les rues de soho des repas 1200
communes près de stockholm des corbeaux
ramasse désormais les mégots de
cigarettes au sol en guise de récompense
ils reçoivent de la nourriture plusieurs
poubelles spéciales ont ainsi été
installés par une start up qui a dressé
les animaux pour s'y rendre et la phase
de tests commencent bien à en croire
cette première vidéo à l'avenir les
volatiles pourrez ramasser d'autres
détritus tant qu'il y aura des gens pour
jeter leurs déchets dans la nature
j'essaie d'approcher
alors à mon tour je me suis mis sur le
dos il s'est retourné sur le dos g
cabrio lilas cabrio l'egypte basculé
vers la barre elle a basculé vers le bas
jallet sur la droite il est sur la
gauche on a dansé et tout d'un coup
elliott m'a interpellé
vous savez très naturel savez toute ma
vie j'ai dit ce que j'avais à
vous n'avez rien reçu pas encore quoi ça
c'est tu vois je te montre
chez moi chez 2012
et d'élégance que ce que vous voulez
j'ai des pics à quelqu'un qu'est-ce qui
avoue quoi tu me sembles
ay quelques instants c'est juste après
le journal de 9h avec un père coudray
anne-claire
poignardé plusieurs fois qu'on met la
pression c'est sans trucage ça a été
postée telle qu'elle est un acte
symbolique physique que j'ai à dire pour
eux illustrait le thème demande
déplacement à madame leur présente à
votre beau département de l'ariège je
connais bien quand même et quel était le
thème de la visite du premier ministre
et donc de son discours l'élu mairie
on met le paquet vous considérez que la
grande majorité des musulmans français a
à coeur cette majorité a à coeur de se
débarrasser des influences étrangères
paradoxalement c'est l'état français qui
maintient une sorte de relation avec les
états d'origine vous développerez et on
développera sa au cours du débat que
l'on démarre avec un chiffre le chiffre
de juin d'autres livres
effectivement comme a dit ce n'est
qu'une bande passante qui passe bien et
oui c'est vrai c'est important bienvenue
au challenge 2022 des prêtres de la
quelqu'un
devant l'organisation avait prévu un
petit déj pour réchauffer tout le monde
ah ouais en fait le show
pour pasqua du spirituel faisait du
spiritueux
pour
lui
[Applaudissements]